vous avez envie de faire quoi après miss
france les papiers et je rêve là
normalement la miss france 2004 et à
tous
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir miss france
merci d'être là alors où il sera sur les
très heureux de pouvoir vous avez donc
été élu donc c'était samedi soir sur tf1
si on peut être sur place et fait un
petit peu de respect pour nous s'il vous
plaît
miss france merci d'être là est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter pour les
français qui ne vous connaissent pas oui
bonjour déjà je m'appelle îles xisha
d'accord je suis là la cousine du
chouchou et le contenu sur le nom depuis
le leem de camille bissière d'accord il
faudra me sert bien sûr l'ami le siècle
où exactement
vous êtes miss quoi mais c'est possible
et vous avez vous savez des passions
chicha mieux et les fruits lait cru et
c'est ma passion papaye goyave noix de
coco et les fruits dans des yaourts et
de saint jal doit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après gmail
après je manger les fruits ça dégouline
comme ça je fais des photos tenu de ma
cuisine
non heureusement qu'à plus jaser de
fontenelle mort et à la culture c'est
important pour une masse est oui quels
sont vos goûts en peinture vous êtes
plutôt monnaies ou rembrandt rembrandt
et j'aime bien ah ouais ouais parce que
ma mère elle avait une machine à laver
rembrandt attendu the new world paul
ouais d'accord mais à sa faveur en
témoigne la photo puisse vous coûter
faire quoi pour changer le monde parce
que maintenant votre parole va compter
déjà je n'aime pas ce journal le monde
je n'aime pas moi je préfère téléphone
je t'ai laissé dire j'aime bien l'accord
très bas messieurs n'en faut pour
changer le monde j'enlèverai des pages
une question basique que tout le monde
se pose vous préférez leur souplesse
important parce que les français ont
besoin de savoir
vous préférez miss france la guerre ou
la paix la guerre onac et c'est pas
facile et lui dire la guerre pour
l'ambiance les pétards
[Rires]
[Musique]
le petit whisky
risquez pas tout ça mais côté festif
bien c'est mal je sais bien vous avez
envie de faire quoi après miss france
les papiers jetables la normale mandat
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rendez vous à la préfecture du tarn
a vu 18
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rendez vous à la préfecture je vais
faire toutes les cartes la carte vitale
pour le docteur d'accord la carte
postale pour les voyages et la carte
grise pour la voiture
d'accord c'est un beau projet voilà et
enfin j'ai pas mal de questions encore à
vous poser c'est quoi votre danse
préférée ma danse préférée danse avec
les stars et danse avec les loups si les
deux dans ce cas d'accord danse avec les
loups c'est très vrai film oui j'aime
bien c'est donc on finit sur vos goûts
en matière d'homme parce que ouattara
nous on a besoin de savoir
voilà la france vers quoi elle se dirige
illich comment l'homme idéal pour france
nommé des halles pour moi c'est un
mélange de milan du champ oui pour le
sourire ouais mokhtar des chevaux que
j'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
m
merci et donc et maître gims parce que
j'aime bien les noirs les fraudes alors
internet
et bien justement voilà d'habitants à
peu près ça j'ai des frissons la highway
j'espère que la beauce et là je peux
regarder la caméra passer un message oui
bien sûr elle est où la caméra elle est
là si jamais tu me regarde toi que
ressemble à ça s'il te ressemble à lui
est comme ça ap le mois sur un portable
away bill france 2015 merci d'être avec
nous vous allez faire des salons et
maintenant c'est ça ouais donc qu'un
salon de la merguez salon de l'ès 6 elle
elle sera dans tous les salons très bien
merci à malte
merci
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]